tout n'est pas clair
dans ce désert mais si je suis
sur terre c'est pour te plaire tout me
plaît ici on a passé des journées on a
pu avoir un petit temps off en équipe
ici on a été au cascade on a été au
volcan bah voilà il y a on profite aussi
ça une bulle un peu de rêve là pour pour
nous quoi c'est trop bien d'être là on
est trop content comme cette mort est
beau
[Musique]
que j'ai jamais rencontré donc je pense
que c'est ça la surprise c'est c'est
comment est-ce que est-ce que les gens
ici connaissent bien pas bien est-ce que
comment elle va être cette rencontre et
j'avoue que je suis assez curieuse de
voir comment ça va se passer
[Musique]
ait
même le rapport à la musique il est très
il est il est très sensuel il est très
j'aime bien il y a quelque chose de très
de très vivant et c'est super inspirant
pour moi de d'être allé voir les
concerts de ce festival ça m'a vraiment
nourri quoi ça va être un chou brûlant
bien sûr on est hyper content de jouer
on a hâte on a fait nos balances tout à
l'heure et j'avais déjà hâte d'être à ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]